A galaxy far, far away almost had a stand-in:
our actual galaxy.
In 2016, when he was still attached to direct
Star Wars Episode IX: The Rise of Skywalker,
Colin Trevorrow told a crowd at the Sundance
Film Festival that he had designs on shooting
scenes for the flick in actual space.
Now, before you suggest that Trevorrow must
have been...well, off his rocker to suggest
such a thing, it may be helpful to know that
it's not like no movie cameras have ever made
the journey to the final frontier.
Most notably, the Warner Bros. documentary
Hubble 3D, which followed a group of astronauts
on a delicate mission to repair the Hubble
Space Telescope, used IMAX cameras to film
space-based scenes.
Of course, these were shot aboard the Space
Shuttle Atlantis and not just, you know, in
open space but the fact remains that movie
cameras did indeed leave our atmosphere to
shoot scenes that we Earthlings would later
watch with our butts planted firmly in movie
theater seats.
Apparently hoping to add a degree of realism
to a series in which ancient orders of mystical
space knights fight each other with laser
swords, Trevorrow informed the crowd that
not only was he hoping to shoot in space,
but that he had actually submitted a request
to the International Space Station to haul
IMAX cameras on up there and start filming
scenes.
Strangely, he had not heard anything in response.
The director admitted:
"I asked the question, 'Is it possible for
us to shoot IMAX film plates in actual space
for Star Wars?'
I haven't gotten an answer yet, but they've
shot IMAX in space!"
While that is true, we hear that special effects
houses are doing really incredible things
these days, and that the starry void is fairly
easily rendered on screen with much less hassle
and expense than it would take to get a film
crew onto the ISS for a month or so.
One could argue that Trevorrow had a strangely
literal sense of what it would take to make
a Star Wars movie, and that argument would
be bolstered by remarks he went on to make
about his intention to shoot Rise of Skywalker
on film, rather than digital.
He said:
"The only place where I tend to not be able
to attach myself entirely to something shot
digitally is when it's a period film.
There's something in my brain that goes, 'Well,
they didn't have video cameras then.'
Film tends to remind us of our memories, of
our childhoods, the way we used to see films.
I could never shoot Star Wars on anything
but film because it's a period film.
It happened a long time ago!"
OK, so we could spend the rest of the day
poking holes in virtually every word of that
statement, but suffice to say that A) we don't
remember seeing any film cameras depicted
in the Star Wars movies, ever, and B) if it
was absolute accuracy Trevorrow was going
for, he should have lobbied to shoot the entire
film as a hologram.
"It's a frickin' hologram."
"Yesss."
Oddly, it would take more than a year and
a half after the Sundance panel for Trevorrow
to be fired from Rise of Skywalker and replaced
with Star Wars Episode VII: The Force Awakens
director J.J. Abrams.
The usual "creative differences" were cited
as the reason for his departure, with nary
a mention of the director's "the hell with
it, let's shoot it in space" phase.
Fortunately, Trevorrow had another blockbuster
franchise to fall back on: Jurassic World,
the first installment of which he directed.
For sequel Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom
and the as-yet untitled upcoming third installment,
Trevorrow relinquished the director's chair
in favor of co-writing the screenplays; we're
going to go ahead and guess that this may
be because he wouldn't quit pitching the idea
of shooting certain scenes in the actual Jurassic
period.
We're poking a lot of fun here, but Trevorrow's
remarks do raise the question of whether any
Hollywood production has ever managed to shoot
footage in actual space.
The answer?
No, but not for lack of trying.
In fact, Christopher Nolan happened to be
sitting on the same panel when Trevorrow dropped
his space bomb, and he revealed that he had
actually attempted the same gambit for his
2014 film Interstellar.
In the intervening years, Nolan has pointed
out that for that excellent effort, he selected
the same IMAX cameras that NASA had previously
used to capture real footage from low Earth
orbit.
But as far as actual space making an appearance
in a Hollywood film, it's never happened,
and it almost certainly will not anytime soon.
Heck, all but the last few minutes of Gravity
took place in space; and if that utterly mind-blowing
flick was able to portray its setting convincingly
without launching Sandra Bullock and George
Clooney into the cosmos, then it's a safe
bet that future filmmakers can do the same.
No, unless and until it becomes cheaper to
deploy space-based film crews than to simply
hire a reputable CGI house, we're not likely
to see any Hollywood features utilizing footage
shot beyond the sad confines of our little
planet.
Somehow, we don't think Star Wars Episode
IX: The Rise of Skywalker will suffer for
the omission; we'll find out when the flick
hits the big screen on December 20.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.